analysis paralysis right they just start
thinking and thinking and thinking
they're frozen from their own thoughts
too many thoughts
and it basically to me it all boils down
to actually fear because if you're
thinking then you're not taking action
and if you're not taking action then
there's no consequence and if there's no
consequence and there's nothing to be
afraid of the overthinking can be an
excuse for actual fear and same thing
with like oh i'm a perfectionist that's
also fear it's fear of not being perfect
then on top of that low confidence
you're not sure yourself so you sit
around and think about doing it instead
of actually doing it
so quit thinking so much
and take action